Dominance is a phenomenon in which one allele
masks the effect of the other.
That’s how we understand it.
But we have also learned that in some cases,
a dominant allele does not completely supress
the recessive one.
The blend of both the genes is seen with an
intermediate phenotype.
And what if both the different genes are dominant?
In such exceptional cases, an individual with
both the phenotypes is obtained.
We have learned all the three types of Dominance
so far!
Let us do a quick review of all the 3 types.
Firstly, can you tell me what Dominance is?
Technically, it can be defined as the relation
between two alleles of a gene and the associated
phenotype.
That means, dominance is all about how one
dominant allele of a particular gene interacts
with the other recessive or dominant allele
of the same gene set in an organism.
So if “T” is one allele from a gene set
which is dominant for the trait “height”,
then its effect on the other allele, which
may be “t” or “T”, is called Dominance!
Based on the gene interactions, Dominance
is categorised into three types.
Complete Dominance which is very common in nature.
And Incomplete and Codominance which are relatively
rare.
Let us review all these three types with one
common and simple example.
We can hypothetically take the alleles “capital
B” and “lower case w” to represent different
flower colours.
Let “B” be the allele for flower colour
blue which we consider as dominant.
The allele for white flowers which will be
a recessive trait will be represented by the
letter “w” in lower case.
So the genotype of the plant with blue flowers
will be “BB” in capital and that of white
flowered plant will be “ww” in lower case
considering both are homozygous!
The first type in the list is complete dominance.
Here, the dominant allele will mask the effect
of the recessive allele completely!
So on crossing the blue and white flowered
plants, we will obtain only blue coloured
flowers.
To be precise, on crossing the two homozygous
varieties, we will get all heterozygous offsprings.
Now this being a case of complete dominance,
all the plants will have blue coloured flowers.
Can you state an example of complete dominance
found in nature?
Most of the dominant traits fall under this category.
For example, the purple colour of flowers,
axial flower position, tall height of the
plant, all these characters found in a pea
plant fall under the category of complete
dominance!
Next in the list is incomplete dominance.
In this type, the dominant allele masks the
effect of the recessive one, but not completely.
That means a phenotype which is intermediate
of the two parents is obtained in the F1 hybrid!
Any guesses what will happen in this case?
If this is a case of incomplete dominance,
then an intermediate of the two colours will
be obtained.
Maybe light blue colour.
Theoretically, “BB” crossed with “ww”
will give us “Bw”.
So genotypically all the F1 hybrids will have
both the alleles.
Phenotypically, all these offsprings will
have an intermediate colour between dark blue
and white!
In nature, incomplete dominance is seen in
plants like the 4o’ clock plants.
In humans, we have seen that incomplete dominance
is seen in hair type.
Curly hair, which is a dominant trait when
crossed with straight hair that is a recessive
trait, gives us wavy hair.
Wavy hair is a trait intermediate of both
the types and hence is an example of INCOMPLETE
dominance!
Now comes the third type, which is called
Codominance!
Let us assume we have another dominant allele
for the “red coloured flower”.
So the genotype of a plant with this coloured
flower will be “RR”.
Any idea what will happen if this plant is
crossed with the one having blue coloured
flowers?
Both “Red” and “Blue” coloured flowers
are dominant traits.
So both the alleles will try getting expressed
with equal strength.
As a result, we will obtain a progeny that
has either blue flowers with red patches or
red flowers with blue patches!
That means both blue and red colours will
be seen in the flowers!
Theoretically, the cross of “RR” and “BB”
will yield F1 hybrids with the genotype “RB”.
As a result, flowers having petals with both
colors will be obtained!
Codominance is found widely in nature!
Most common examples of Codominance that we
have learnt include the human blood groups,
coat colour in cattle and in many other animals.
Mendelism revolves around complete dominance,
as it doesn’t favour blending of characters.
Hence, the other two types: Incomplete and
Codominance, are commonly studied as exceptions
to Mendelism.